en el área occidental se han dado pues
algunas
desabastecimientos sobre todo en el tema
del combustible lo mismo estaba
sucediendo en en la provincia de colón y
bocas del toro que son provincias
atlánticas otra cosa que está pasando en
este momento es la desesperación de
muchos de los productores como lo reseña
vas pues ya se dieron varios incidentes
no es la primera vez que se dan este es
el más sonado y también otra cosa que
está sucediendo es que algunos partidos
políticos han comenzado a acercarse a la
mesa de diálogo una mesa de diálogo es
accidentada y que está representada por
minorías minorías porque el gobierno es
minoritario y las organizaciones que se
encuentran sentadas allí también lo son
los partidos políticos no se encuentran
representados los industriales no se
encuentran representados solamente un
sindicato que se encuentra ahí entonces
el pueblo mira desde la barrera lo que
está sucediendo en la provincia de coclé
y lamentablemente va bastante lento este
momento las negociaciones que se han
centrado en la canasta básica familiar
lo que sorprende a muchos en panamá
porque todos sabemos que este es un
problema mundial lo cual pues va a
derivar en que se va a llegar a un
acuerdo que eventualmente no va a tener
ningún resultado porque la canasta
básica va a subir
lamentablemente sí o sí y usted hablaba
de la mesa única de diálogo que comenzó
el jueves para intentar encontrar
precisamente una salida de las protestas
sin embargo esta no es la primera
conversación y de hecho la semana pasada
fracasaron los acercamientos en que
radican las diferencias y las
dificultades para negociar
bueno primero en la representación a ver
en panamá las am si uno mira el mapa de
la asamblea nacional los sectores
indígenas están sobrerrepresentados en
la asamblea nacional los sectores que
están negociando en este momento sus
sectores indígenas minoritarias y ese
parte del problema hay otros sectores
que no se sienten representados ellos
están cerrando vías algunos están
pidiendo tierras otros están pidiendo
cosas tan
extrañas como la que los obligó por
exprés desaparezcan del país y eso es
una labor que requiere de políticas
públicas de las cuales tampoco se está
hablando el tema de las políticas
públicas no se está hablando y la agenda
que se ha llevado de una agenda muy
particular de grupos a algunos pues muy
centrados hacia la izquierda en un país
donde la izquierda está muy dividida tan
dividida que el sector más político de
la izquierda es parte del propio
gobierno y ante estas exigencias cuál ha
sido la respuesta del gobierno de
laurentino cortizo
bueno hasta ahora ha llegado tarde la
ayuda a las personas que se están
quedando desabastecidas no se tomaron
las medidas correctas para lograr que la
cadena de abastecimientos se lograra
para más un país que tiene aeropuertos
en todas las provincias y tienen puertos
en todas las provincias lo cual es
sorprendente que nosotros en la ciudad
tengamos problemas de abastecimiento con
las legumbres sobre todo en el interior
del país tengan desabastecimiento de
combustible y de gas este tipo de
situaciones ha hecho que se le dé muchas
críticas al gobierno que por cierto se
ha centrado en la derogatoria de
proyectos que eran cuestionados por el
propio pr por el propio partido de
gobierno entonces da la impresión de que
el gobierno ha aprovechado también para
sacar un poco la basura política que
tenía almacenada y pues estar tranquilos
internamente ya que recordemos también
que el presidente laurent y no cortizo
es un presidente externo del partido es
un presidente recién llegado al partido
de gobierno